-You mentioned --
and I remember last summer
we were talking a fair amount.
You were so excited
to be going off to New Zealand
to shoot "Sweet Tooth."
Was New Zealand as wonderful
as you hoped it would be?
-It's -- It is a magical place
It's so cool. It's beautiful
It's also very interesting
There's a lot of
volcanic activity down there
So there are
interesting things, like -
There's this place that I loved.
It's called Kerosene Creek
And it's basically
a geothermally warmed river,
which is like having a hot tub
mixed with a river.
So I went down there.
My friends Maclain and Clair
were down there,
and Libby and I
went down to this creek.
And me and my buddy Maclai
were doing slow-mo rise-up
through the water.
Just, you know, just --
It just is the coolest setting
Anyway --
-Here's a good picture, a phot
of, like, the sort of
slow-motion action-movie -
Yeah. That's -- Yeah.
I think we get a sense.
-Well, about 20 minutes into u
trying to get these perfec
"rise out of the water" shot
in slow mo, this guy says,
[German accent]
"Excuse me. Uh, I need to --
I don't think you want to be
doing what you're doing."
Yeah, you're not the only on
who can do a German accent
Seth.
And we were like,
"What, German tourist?
What are you talking about?"
He said, "There are
brain-eating amoebas
in these waters."
And we said, "Brain -- What?!"
"Amoebas. They eat your brains."
And we're like, "Oh, okay.
So we, you know, start digging
the water out of our ears
and make our way to the exit
And he's like, "Oh, I hope
I did not ruin your day."
Like, "Oh, no, no, we --
This has been great.
And thanks for waiting friggin
20 minutes to let us know
as we're dunking our head unde
right in front of you."
So, we go up to the front.
We're like,
"Oh, well, they've got to
probably have pla--
How'd we miss the warning sign
about this?"
So, we go up, and there are al
these "don't litter" signs
"Here is an appropriate
place to park."
Nowhere on there is it saying,
"Warning.
There's an amoeba down there
that could eat your entire brain
and leave you just, like, yo
know, in a puddle of flesh."
And so we thought it was a joke,
but we looked it up.
It's a real thing.
It doesn't happen very often
but still, like,
I think it's at least wort
a casual mention on the sign
-Yeah, I feel like that's more
than fair to ask for that.
Did you like
where you ended up staying
'Cause I assume that productio
decided where to put you up.
-Yes, I loved
where I was staying.
We stayed in Auckland,
but when we went over,
you have to quarantine
for two weeks.
And we went down. You don't ge
to pick where you quarantine
They just put you on a bus
or a plane
and send you off to a hotel.
And we went to this place
called Rotorua,
which, again,
a lot of geothermal activity
This is a place that essentially
because of all
the geothermal activity,
the entire town
smells like farts.
And it was like,
"Oh, these guys know my work."
[ Laughter ]
So it was --
It's really an interesting
and cool town,
and you get used to that.
But it is something that
your nose has to, you know
contend with for a little bit.
-Um, hopefully, you will
allow me this indulgence.
The last time you were here,
you read a scene
from "MacGruber,"
the upcoming series
that will be on Peacock.
Would you be so kind
as to read us another piec
from this incredibly highl
anticipated television event
-I would love to.
And thank you for asking.
I'm gonna put my reading glasses
on because I am old.
So, this is a scene in which
I'm explaining to Kristen Wiig
and Ryan Phillippe's characters,
Vicki and Piper,
the importance of this mission
It's pretty self-explanatory
There are spoilers.
So, what I have done is
I've covered up the spoilers
with the word "spoiler."
Just so --
That's something to know.
Okay. Here we go.
Let me take a little...
Vodka in there.
Red vodka. Okay.
"Piper, why do you think
I hid that spoiler
in a [bleep] spoiler
for 20 years?
For gigs and shiggles?
No, I hid it 'cause
no government on Earth
should have it.
Not even the United States
of spoiler.
I mean, we're talking abou
a world-ender here, Piper,
and I don't know about you
but I kind of like the world
I like sunsets.
I like snow-capped mountains
I like kicking back with a col
Molson and watching the game
I like babies and kettle corn,
monster trucks and puppy dogs,
tig ol' biddies
and bunchin' mox.
I even like cancer
and type II diabetes
because they remind me
that life is precious.
And that's why it is imperativ
that we keep this spoiler
out of spoiler's hands!"
[ Laughter ]
-Well, I think
I speak for everyone
when I say we are
eagerly anticipating this.
Thank you, dear friend.
I appreciate you making time
-Thank you very much.
And just so you know,
it's not just stuff like that.
There's tons of farts
and [bleep] in it, as well
[ Laughter ]
-"Sweet Tooth"
is streaming now on Netflix,
and "HouseBroken" airs
Monday nights on Fox.